hey youtubers is Charlotte so a lot of
people are talking about the Tarot joy
on Game of Thrones season six
they're just there's a location that
they're supposed to be filming at in
spate like it's in Guadalajara that
looks like it might be the Tower of joy
so I'm just gonna break down why
everyone thinks that's such a big deal
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far so
here we go the Tarot joy is the place
where Rhaegar Targaryen took Lyanna
stark when he absconded with her prior
to Robert's rebellion it was like the
first thing in a sequence of events that
led to Robert's rebellion that there was
a lot of other reasons for the rebellion
but it all started with Rhaegar going
rogue and taking Lyanna stark when you
look at the map here it's really like up
at the northern edge of Dorne the red
mountains themselves are pretty famous
just because the the Dornish people were
able to use them to repel Aegon the
conquerer during the war of conquest as
you can see where it sits here it's
highly defensible so it just it's a very
advantageous position either as a
lookout tower or just as a point of
defense for any defending army before
Rhaegar Targaryen came along though it
was just a normal tower he is the one
that named it the Tower of joy the first
time that we learn about it is actually
in the first book when Ned Stark is
under the milk of the poppy
and he starts recalling the showdown at
the Tower of joy so when people talk
about the Tower of joy there's two
different things there's the physical
tower itself and then there's the big
event the showdown at the Tower of joy
where Ned Stark Talon Reed and a couple
other people went to rescue Lyanna Stark
they ended up fighting Arthur Dayne and
a couple other Kingsguard that had been
left there by Rhaegar Targaryen to
protect Lyanna Stark there's a lot of
conjecture about you know what was
really going on there so that's why
everyone is hoping that we get to see it
in season 6 there's really two big ways
that they could do that they could do a
literal flashback like we did was
Circe's flashback although you could
argue that she was remembering that and
we were seeing her memory or they could
use a weirwood flashback which isn't
something we haven't seen on the show
yet so I'm like I'm not gonna explain it
yet just to avoid spoilers but if you
know what I'm talking about and you want
to talk about it just please use spoiler
tags in the comments it's just that
there are a couple story devices that
George R Martin uses in the books to
talk about events that happen in the
past so far we've only seen one of those
on the show so I'm just gonna read this
just as Ned Stark is remembering it this
is like right out of book one they were
seven facing three and he's talking
about
Howland Reed and his other companions
that wrote in with him they faced
Sir Arthur Dayne sword of the morning
Sir Gerald Hightower and surahs' well
went
so obviously the Gerold Hightower and
Oswald went they aren't complete
nobodies Ned had noticed that they were
missing at the Battle of the Trident
which is Rhaegar supposedly died and the
sack of King's Landing so this is
basically after Robert has won the
rebellion Arthur Dayne and the other
Kingsguard refused to bend the knee
despite the fact that they had lost the
war Arthur Dayne being one of the best
swordsmen to ever live almost ended up
killing Ned Stark but he and Howland
Reed were able to defeat him together
when it was all over they found Leon a
stark lying in a bed with blood all
around her and as he's remembering it
under the milk of the poppy he just
remembers making a promise to her as she
lay dying in the timeline after that Ned
Stark took Arthur Danes blade dawn his
ancestral blade back to his home at
Starfall and gave it to his sister they
just they have a tradition where they
passed the blade down to the most worthy
person in their house after that he
returned to Winterfell with Jon Snow in
tow as Catelyn Stark remembers it he
came home from the war with a baby so
there's a lot of conjecture as to like
where that baby came from a lot of
people think that you know because Ned
Stark spent time at Starfall that ashara
dayne was the mother but the biggest
part of the phantom believes that the
promise that Lyanna Stark extracted from
Ned Stark had to do with Jon Snow that
Jon Snow was the baby born at the Tower
of joy and that's that's what all the
blood was from and she just died from
childbirth
so everybody like raises their hand and
says you know hey wait you know why why
can't Ned Stark tell Jon Snow who his
real mother is why is it such a secret
why is it so important that he protect
that the best theory is to why that
needed to remain so secret is is because
it would have plunged the kingdom into
another Civil War and everyone wanted to
prevent that imagine if it were true
that Jon Snow were really a Targaryen
really the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna stark as we know right now all of
Circe's children are Impostors that
think they're all true Lannisters so it
wouldn't be too much of a stretch to
think that some of the Great Houses
would rally behind a new candidate with
true Targaryen blood that's why Varys
interior are so excited about Daenerys
coming to Westeros
because they're like we totally
understand how the great houses work we
understand politics you need to get them
to rally behind you you need their
support as of right now people don't
seem really hot on the Queen she just
did that big walk of shame and she's
gonna go on a huge tear now just see the
look in her eyes and she's being carried
away by the mountain Kings Landing in
season six is a powder keg waiting to go
off if a secret Targaryen were to emerge
someone who's been a proven leader up at
the wall then it would just fan those
flames so that's probably why everyone
involved with what happened at the
territoy want to keep it such a big
secret as far as we know like there's
only a couple people that could confirm
Jon Snow's parentage though that they
could confirm that that's true there's
Howland Reed who's still alive in the
books and on the show we haven't seen
him on the show so we just have to
assume that he's still alive floating
around somewhere and then there's anyone
that Rhaegar may have secretly told
about what he was doing like maester
aemon for instance he's someone that he
corresponded with on a regular basis
maester aemon of course is very very
dead right now but he kept very good
records at the Nights Watch so there's
just like a number of roundabout ways
that we could find out what happened at
the Tower of joy and really the only
reason to show it would be to confirm
what happened between Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna stark that's why everyone is
thinking about Jon Snow and Arthur Dayne
so much just because the show looked
like it was casting someone that sounded
like Arthur Dayne I've already done a
casting video and I did a Arthur Dayne
video so it links for those in the
description let me know that you know
just based on like some of these
shooting locations do you think that the
show is going to do a tower of joy scene
whether it be a flashback or in
present-day that the reason people think
that it's a flashback is because Ned
Stark destroyed the tower after Robert's
rebellion
so if Game of Thrones is shooting at
something that looks like the Tower of
joy and they don't make it look like
it's torn out like they don't use CG to
destroy it then it has to be a flashback
and the only reason you would flashback
to the Tower of joy is if you wanted to
do a Lyanna stark death moment the other
theory about about the Arthur Dayne
flashback is that it was a flashback to
the spawning night and it would be
Jaime's flashback because Arthur Dayne
saved him from being killed the person
that the show is casting is just someone
who's supposed to use a legendary blade
in the actor that they want to find
needs to be a really
awesome swordsman in real life amongst
the list of legendary blades in Game of
Thrones the most legendary is dawn it's
older than all the Valyrian swords that
we've seen on the show and it's made
from a fallen meteor so if you want to
learn more about Arthur Dayne and his
sword just watch my Arthur Dayne video
just to recap some of the comic-con
business that happened last week a lot
of people were disappointed because they
didn't show us who the new cast was
there were a lot of theories about why
people were missing certain actors were
there having babies or they were filming
other stuff so that's not the big deal
the big deal is is they're not saying
anything about season 6 other than
Margaery Tyrell hinting that she may not
have the Queen of thorns around to help
her out in season 6 that doesn't mean
that she's gonna die that doesn't mean
the queen of thorns is gonna die she
could just go back to Highgarden but
that was like literally the only thing
that we learned about season 6 that in
the fact that the actors were being held
to much stronger security clauses about
information leaks so really if if
there's anything to look forward to in
season 6 is it that this show will
confirm some really big fan theories or
destroy them completely forever either
way lots of answers are coming even
though I think the show is gonna get a
season 7 so it might hold some of the
biggest fan theories to season 7 that's
actually a really good question to ask
you guys so if the show is gonna get
seven seasons would you rather they hold
like the biggest secrets to that very
last season or would you rather find out
who Jon Snow's mother is in season six
no matter what happens I feel like 50%
of the Phantom is gonna be disappointed
so just to make you guys happier I'll
announce this week's giveaway winner or
the the Comic Con giveaway winner Erik
van cleve and April gems you guys both
went $20 Amazon gift cards be sure to
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact info and
there's a new round of the giveaway now
all you have to do just you know be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
the weekly Game of Thrones giveaway it's
gonna continue indefinitely so I'm gonna
try and stick to my weekly Game of
Thrones bonus video schedule and I will
do a Q&A tomorrow like we're back to the
normal schedule now that comic-con is
over so I think what I'm gonna do for my
next bonus video is pick like a couple
big events from Jaime Lannister's
history just just because I think his
characters gonna go in a really
interesting direction in season six but
if they're any other you know bonus
videos you guys want me to do just let
me know in the comments while you guys
wait for that stuff you can click here
to learn all about Arthur
Dane's history and you can click here
for all my comic-con videos I've just
done a whole bunch of trailer videos
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you